when it comes to Dark Souls your skills  and battle will only take you so far  eventually you'll need to drink from  that magical healing Estus flask it  wouldn't it be cool to own one of those  things in real life well now you can  thanks to prima games prima games is  releasing the official Dark Souls 3  strategy guide and if you spring for the  special edition you'll get your very own  Estus flask replica you'll also get a  dark side notebook and great sword  bookmark the whole package will run you  124 bucks and it will only be available  in limited quantities Stark Souls 3 hits  ps4 xbox one and pc on April twelfth and  we're all going to need plenty of Estus  flasks when that time rolls around until  then stay tuned to gamespot for all the  Dark Souls news you need we are so ready  to fight that giant tree monster  you